I heard that you worked in a beauty
parlor when you were younger well my
sister my sister Angie my oldest sister
was a beautician and she that's she did
see when I was a kid in Jersey I worked
all the time from the time I was like uh
13 14 12 13 years old I worked in a at
the church selling soda at bingo night
right that was mying like a Friday night
yeah that was my big thing and then the
next job I had basically when I got my
working papers where putting little kids
on the rides like down at the I'm from
Asbury Park New Jersey yeah yeah you
know you have like the little kitties
who come and they'd have the like the
little little fire engine you know they
have the the little truck or the car and
you and you put them on you stick the
little strap across me you go ring the
bell ring the bell you know honk the
horn and they go around a circle they
didn't really drive you know yeah did
you ever have the kids that were
terrified but their parents were like
smile baby yeah yeah oh yeah and well it
was way before all the all the uh little
cell phones and stuff so we didn't have
to have we had you know disposable
cameras Oh my God I lived with them I
remember when they came out with the
ones that went underwater and I was like
my mind was blowing that was like
amazing that one yeah and I never took
good pictures me neither always like
even like they're like this was taken on
an iPhone you see those Billboards I'm
like not on mine not on my phone yeah I
don't take good picture my sister I was
saying she had a beauty po so when I I
did things like I was a gardener I
worked you know did did things shovel
snow in winter I worked for a guy who
had a a gardening business in the summer
and she said what are you going to do
you know now you're now of high school
you you know and I wasn't going to go to
college and she said well why don't you
come to work for me I got the beauty p
and I said Angie what do I look like a
pan to you what am I going to do she
said so I'm going to send you to school
so I said okay so all summer she prepped
me for this uh school started in
September in in asur it's called the
will
AC beauty academy or something like that
and I was dragging my feet like crazy I
was going a Andrew I don't know if this
is going to work out you know this is
like I don't know if I'm she's now come
on and then Aunt so and so know we would
do pin curls and comb outs and teasing
and you know more about hair than I do I
I you know Perman waves color did all
this stuff and then I go so I go to
school first day I go to school she
bought me the whole thing you had the
you had this this the white SM and she
had all the tools in the kit and I said
oh God I don't know if I'm going to be
able to do this and I walk up these
stairs and really hesitant and I open
the door and in this big room with all
these stations with with little wig
blocks and stuff all around behind was a
coffee bar uh and there were 35 women in
there all my age and they were going and
I went what
what the hell and I I went immediately I
didn't go in I went downstairs and was
pay phones then you know I went down and
called Angie I said Angie I owe you for
the rest
of I knew you're going to go you're
going to walk in and tell those women
yeah I was like I I it was seriously
like dying and going to heaven and it
was a great I the you know and then
working was good too but the the study
working yeah really the studying
yeah oh my God I love you
[Music]
[Applause]
so thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home